don't worry Kelly will be training you
first Kelly's training us
[Music]
I don't have a headache
I'm just preparing
did you scoot over here on my dress
but you're not supposed to wear a white
to a wedding I know but there was an
emergency
I look really good in white
color I think it's a person hot dogs
basically anything that is awesome snow
cones Michael wanted me to ask you how
to raise your desk chair
it's the lever on the side that's what I
told them thanks
oh my God he is so cute
would you talk to him for me and see if
he likes me
I don't think I can oh please Jim please
please Jim please please please he's so
cute I like him so much and I would do
it but I'm too shy please Jim please
please please please please Jim please
please please well I manage my
department and I've been doing that for
several years now and God I've learned a
lot of life lessons along the way
your Department's just you right yes Jim
but I am not easy to manage hey Kelly
what's up nothing
oh except oh my God Jim last night
finally hooked up it was awesome that's
great I'm really happy I know and it was
so funny because we were at this bar
with his friend and I was sitting next
to him the whole night
so long and then he kissed me and I
didn't know what to say so I said Ryan
what took you so long and you just said
to him can you believe that wow oh my
God Jim is that embarrassing I'm
embarrassed no don't be no thank God
because I was nervous damn you will not
believe I was so nervous but now now I
have a boyfriend
I hooked up with her on February 13th
how did Ryan use it as an object as an
object try and use me as an object what
has two skinny chicken legs and sexy
ping pong hi Kelly because she's
boyfriend it is I don't want to guess
I'll give you a hint it's not my
boyfriend I think it's a guy over here
I don't talk trash I talk smack they're
totally different trash talk is all
hypothetical like your mom is so fat she
could eat the internet but smack talk is
happening like right now like you're
ugly and I know it for a fact cause I
get the evidence right there your
boyfriend is so weak he needs Tara is
just a watch baseball Jim couldn't hit a
ping pong ball if it was the size of the
moon were Jim's parents first cousins
that were also bad at ping pong if I had
created a website with this many
problems I'd kill myself do you have a
question Kelly yeah I have a lot of
questions number one how dare you
you to tell me that you care about me
that is what I want Kelly I'm your boss
now okay you can't keep talking to me
like I'm your boyfriend oh big strong
man fancy new whatever I don't think you
ever cared about me I never cared about
you six months ago Karen filipelli sent
me an email asked me out I said no
because I was committed to our
relationship well I hope you're still
committed because I'm I'm pregnant
and guess what buddy I am
okay okay do you feel prepared to help
me raise a baby
I can't talk about this right now okay
after work we'll go out to dinner we'll
talk about it then okay
we have a date
I never really thought about death until
Princess Diana died that was the saddest
funeral ever
that and my sisters
that is a great idea ultimatums are key
basically nobody does anything for me
anymore unless I threaten to kill myself
this summer I did the minority executive
training program at Yale
you guys I'm like really smart now you
don't even know you could ask me Kelly
what's the biggest company in the world
and I'd be like blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah giving you the exact
right answer
I'm really excited to introduce you guys
to Ryan Howard he has achieved a great
deal in the last week no achievement is
greater than is on again off-again
girlfriend what do you
who am I I'm Kelly Kapoor the business
it is important to Brand yourself
so I have a couple things in the works
the business the diet the
shopping the etiquette for
all their generosity of spirit they
password protect their Wireless try
Jesus Opus name was the top of the queue
so number five becomes number four
number six becomes number five number
three becomes number two etc etc and
let's just say that I just sent back
Love Actually which was awesome and they
sent me Uptown Girls which is also
awesome but guess what now I want to see
Love Actually again but it's at the
bottom of the queue oh no what do I do
what I do is this I go online I go click
click click and I change the order of
the queue so I can see Love Actually as
soon as I want to it's so easy Ryan
do you really not know how Netflix works
yes I forgot
you're such a dick
Ryan well done two minutes 42 seconds
additionally Pam you win 10 because she
said awesome 12 times and Jim you win
five because she mentioned six romantic
comedies everyone may have your
attention
I would like to introduce you to Mr
Denny cordray he is going to be joining
us as our new traveling salesman say
hello to Danny
me okay you know what yeah
oh my God
oh my god really yes Tom Cruise and
Katie Holmes they had a baby and they
named it Surrey and then Brad Pitt and
Angelina Jolie they had a baby too and
they named it Shiloh and both babies are
amazing great
what's new with you I just told you
if I get to stay and Ryan is laid off I
will kill myself
like Romeo and Juliet
the Claire Danes one what about second
base like if Michael said he got to
second base with you does that mean you
like closed a deal that's me I mean
that's a baseball term right I don't
know what Michael is talking about I
don't know I cannot wait to visit Ryan
in prison
I'm gonna wear my hottest track suit and
get my hair done and then be like hi Ron
and then all the other prisoners are
gonna be like damn Ryan you got a hot
ex-girlfriend oh I would never treated
her so bad when I was outside of prison
well if you don't have to do them
Meredith what are you doing I could be
pregnant okay no oh my resolution was to
get more attention nope she's lying well
I just need to know where this is going
hey
I like you
all right
it's not too late
but you need to access your uncrazy side
otherwise maybe this thing is run its
course
don't you dare walk away from me Daryl
Philbin you are the most selfish person
I've ever met in my time
take it over
Daryl Philbin is the most complicated
man that I have ever met I mean who says
exactly what they're thinking
what kind of game is that